hello everyone
thanks for coming to the site trek it's
awesome to see it packed out in here can
everyone give me a stretch that's good I
need to stretch so I look less weird
okay so I want to talk about the event
loop and what the heck is the event loop
as in the event loop inside JavaScript
so first up as he said I work for and
yet which is an awesome little dev shop
slash product company in the u.s. look
us up if you need help with real-time
stuff that's what we're good at so about
18 months ago I'm a paid professional
JavaScript developer I thought to myself
how does like JavaScript actually work
and I wasn't entirely sure
I'd heard v8 as a term you know Chrome's
runtime didn't really know what that
meant what that did
I'd heard things like single-threaded
you know obviously I'm using callbacks
how to call backs work so I kind of
started a journey of like reading and
research and experimenting in the
browser which basically started like
this right I kind of was like JavaScript
what are you and it's like I'm a single
threaded on blocking asynchronous
concurrently glitch right that's uh yeah
cool I have a call stack an event leave
a callback queue and some other api's
and stuff right I did not do a computer
science degree I don't I mean these
words they're words so you know I heard
of like v8 and the various runtimes in
different browsers so I like look to v8
and said you have a cool stack an event
leave a callback queue and some other
guys and stuff I have a call stack and a
heap I don't know what those other
things are okay interesting
so basically 18 months pass like for 18
months later now and like I think I
think I get this
and so this is what I want to share with
you today so hopefully this will be
useful if you're relatively new to
JavaScript help you understand why
javascript is so weird when you compare
it to other languages you might have
used why callbacks are a thing which
calls us hell but are required and also
if you're not if you're an experienced
JavaScript developer hopefully give you
some kind of fresh insights into how the
runtime that you're using everyday works
so that you can kind of think about it a
little better so if we look at the
JavaScript runtime itself like v8 for
example which is the runtime inside
Chrome this is what is this is a
simplified view really of what the
JavaScript runtime is it's a heap which
is we don't need to worry about that
it's kind of boring it's just like where
memory allocation happens and then
there's the call stack which is where
you're like stack frames are and all
that kind of stuff but if you like clone
the v8 code base and grep for things
like set timeout or Dom or xml
httprequest they're not in there they
don't exist in v8 which is kind of a
surprise to me right like set time
that's one of those like first things
you use in JavaScript when you start
thinking about async stuff and it's not
in the v8 source hmm interesting so over
this 18 months of discovery I've come to
realize that this is really this is
really the bigger picture and this is
what I'm hoping to get you all kind of
on board with today and understand what
these pieces are so we have the v8
runtime but then we have these things
called web api s which are extra things
that the browser provides so the dom
ajax set timeout things like that then
we have this mythical event loop and the
callback queue I'm sure you've heard
some of these terms before but maybe
don't quite understand how these pieces
like pull together so I'm going to start
from the beginning some of this will be
new to or you know the words might be
new to people other other people might
get this but we're going to quickly kind
of move on from here so so bear with me
if this is if this is obvious but I
think for a lot of people it's not so
javascript is a single-threaded program
language single threaded runtime which
means it has a single call stack and it
can do one thing at a time like that
what a single thread means is like the
program can run one one piece of code at
a time so let's try and visualize that
just to kind of to get our heads around
what that means so if I have some code
like this on the on your left we've got
a few functions a function multiplier
which multiplies two numbers square
which calls multiplied with that you
know the same number twice a function
which prints the square of a number by
calling Square and then calling console
at log and then at the bottom of a file
we actually run prints square write this
code all good
makes sense cool so if we run this well
I should back up a step sorry so the
call stack is basically it's a data
structure which records basically where
in the program we are so if we step into
a function we push something onto the
stack if we return from a function we
pop off the top of the stack that's all
the stack can do we pushed up on the top
pop off the top so if we run this file
well there's kind of a main function
right like the the file itself so we
push that onto the stack then we have
some function definitions there just
like defining the state of the world and
then finally we get to print square
right
so print square is a function call so we
pushed onto the stack and immediately
inside print square we're gonna call
square we're going to push them to the
stack which calls multiply and now we
hit a return statement
right we've multiplied a and B and we
return so I said when we return we pop
something off the stack so pop multiply
off the stack return into square returns
print Square console dot log
print square is now there's no return
but it's implicit because we got to the
end of the function and we're done right
so that that is like a visualization of
the call stack does that make sense yes
Bo ok great so even if you haven't
really thought about or visualized the
call stack before you've undoubtedly
come across it when you've been doing
certainly browser side development so if
we have code like this a function bars
which calls bar which calls foo which
throws an error then if we run this in
Chrome will we see something like this
in the dev tools right on core error
oops and it prints the stack trace that
is the stack trace right the state of
the stack when that error happened so
I'm call arrow oops which was called in
foo which was called by bar which is
called by bars which is called by this
function which is our main right equally
if you've heard the term like blowing
the stack then this is an example of
that right have a function free which
calls foo so what's gonna happen well we
run main we call foo which calls foo
which calls foo which calls foo and
ultimately chrome says well you probably
didn't mean to call foo sixteen thousand
times recursively so I'll just like kill
things for you and you can figure out
where your bug lies right so although I
may be representing a new kind of side
of the call stack you've probably got
some sense of it in your development
practice already so the big question
then have comes is like what happens
when things are slow so we talked about
blocking and blocking behavior and
blocking there's no strict definition of
what isn't isn't blocking really it's
just code that is slow right so console
dot log is not very slow doing a while
loop from 1 to 10 billion is kind of
slope doing image processing is slow
Network requests are slow so things
which are slow and on that stack are
what a blocking are blocking means so
here's a little example so let's say we
have this is like a fake fake bit of
code get synchronous right like jQuery
is like Ajax requests what would happen
if those were synchronous requests so
forget what we know about a sink Kovacs
they're synchronous so if we just go
through it like we have been we call get
sink and then we wait right because
we're doing network requests networks
relative to computers are very very slow
hopefully that Network request completes
we can move on wait move on wait and I
mean this network request might never
finish so yeah I guess I'll go home
finally those three you know blocking
behavior is complete and we can clear
the stack right so in a programming
language which is single threaded you're
not using threads like say Ruby like
that's what happens right we make a
network
we have to just wait till it's done
because we we have no way of handling
that so why is this actually a problem
the problem is because we are running
code in browsers so let's I can it okay
here we go okay so this is just this is
chrome this is the code I just ran I
browsers don't give us what they do
actually go a synchronously Ajax request
but I'm actually just faking this out
with a big while loop because while
loops are synchronous
so I basically while loop for like a
second or five seconds I think before
continuing so if I open up the console
here we can see what happens so we
request foo calm and like while this is
happening I can't do anything right look
even the Run button hasn't finished
re-rendering the fact that I previously
clicked it because the browser is
blocked it's stuck
it can't do anything until those
requests complete and then all hell
breaks loose right because I did some
stuff and it figured out that I'd done
it it just couldn't actually like render
it can do anything and that's because if
that call stack has things on it and
here it's got these um yeah it's still
going uh-huh
we've got the synchronous requests right
we've blocked the call stack the browser
can't do anything else they can't render
it can't run any other code it's stuck
not ideal right if we want people to
have nice fluid you guys we can't block
the stack so so how do we handle this
well the simplest solution were provided
with is asynchronous callbacks right so
there are almost no blocking functions
in the browser equally nodes they're all
made asynchronous which basically means
we run some code give it a callback and
we run that later right we know what if
you've been writing JavaScript you've
seen asynchronous callbacks what does
this actually look like so simple
example throw my people just where we're
at code like this console dialog hi
right we run this at timeout
but that queues the console log for the
future somehow so then we skip straight
on to J's call for you log that and then
five seconds later we log there right
makes sense happy basically like that
set timeout is doing something so
asynchronous callbacks with regards to
the stack we saw before how does this
work so let's run the code console to
look hi set timeout okay what's going to
happen here we know that console.log
there doesn't run immediately it's going
to run in five seconds time we can't
push that concert log onto the stack so
somehow it just disappears we we don't
have like a way of describing this yet
but we'll come to it we log just can't
for you clear and then five seconds
later somehow magically console.log
there appears on the stack how does that
happen
and that's this is basically where the
event Li comes in and concurrency right
so I've been kind of partially lying to
you and telling you that JavaScript can
only do one thing at time that is true
javascript the runtime can only do one
thing at a time it can't make an AJAX
request while you're doing other code it
can't do a set timeout while you do
another cook the reason we can do things
concurrently is that the browser is more
than just the runtime so remember this
diagram the JavaScript runtime can do
one thing at a time but the browser
gives us these other things right gives
us these web api's these are effectively
threads that you can't access like
threads you can just like make calls to
and those pieces of the browser aware
this concurrency kicks in if you're a
back-end person this diagram looks
basically identical for node except
instead of web api is we have c++ api's
right and the the threading and all that
stuff is hidden from you by being
running like c++ lab okay so now that we
have this picture let's see how this
code runs in this kind of more full
picture of what a browser looks like so
same as before run the code console log
by log hide the console simple now we
can see what happens when we call set
timeout so we call set timeout we are we
pass this callback function and a delay
to the set timeout call now set timeout
is an API provided to us by the browser
remember I said it doesn't live like in
the v8 source it's like extra
we get in the environment we're running
the JavaScript runtime in so effectively
we kick off a timer right in like the
browser kicks off the timer for you
and now it's going to handle it's going
to handle the countdown for you right so
that means that our set timeout call
itself is now complete so we can pop off
the stack just can't for you clear so
now we've got this timer in the Web API
which five seconds later is going to
complete now the Web API can't just like
start modifying your code right it can't
just like Chuck stuck on to the stack
when it's ready because if it did it
would like just appear randomly in the
middle of your code so this is where the
task queue or the callback queue kicks
in so basically any of the web api is
when they're done they push your call
call back on to the task queue and
finally we get to the event loop the
title of the talk is what the heck is
the event loop the event loop is like
the simplest little piece in this whole
equation and it has one very simple job
the event leaves job is to look at the
stack and look at the task queue if the
stack is empty it takes the first thing
on the queue and pushes onto the stack
which effectively runs it right so here
we can see that now the stack is clear
there's a callback on the task queue
Steve only runs it says oh I get to do
something here pushes the callback back
onto the stack now remember the stack is
like JavaScript land right this is back
inside v8 so the callback appears on the
stack and gets run console the log there
and we're done does that make sense
everyone with me awesome
ok so now we can see how this works with
probably one of the first encounters
you'd have had with async stuff which is
when for some weird reason someone says
oh you have to call set time at zero
like ok you want me to run the function
in zero time why would I wrap it in a
set timer like the first time you come
across this if you're anything like me
you're like okay well I sort of see
that's doing something but I don't
really know why and the reason is
generally if you're trying to defer
something until the stack is clear right
so we know looking at this um if you run
JavaScript that we're just going to see
the same result we're going to see hi
we're going to see
jas called for you and then there is
going to somehow appear at the end so
running it we can see how that happens
consider like high set time at zero now
that's going to complete immediately and
push the call back onto the queue but
remember I said about the event loop it
has to wait until the stack is clear
before it can push the call back onto
the stack so your stack is going to
continue to run right your main files
going to continue to run consider like
John Jay has called for you
and clear now that we're clear the event
loop can kick in or in your callback so
that's like an example of set time at
zero is like pushing deferring that
execution of code for whatever reason to
the end of a stack or until the stack is
clear okay so all these web api's work
the same way right if we have Ajax
requests we make an AJAX request to URL
with a callback just works the same way
oops sorry console.log hi make an AJAX
request the code for running that ajax
request does not live in the JavaScript
runtime lives in the browser as a web
api so we spin up a xhr web api with a
callback in the URL your code can
continue to run until the xhr request
completes or doesn't complete it may
never complete but that's okay your
stack can continue to run assuming it
does complete callback gets pushed onto
the queue picked up by the event loop
and it's run right that's all that
happens when an async call happens okay
so let's do a crazy complicated example
so I hope this is gonna work
if you hadn't kind of realized like oh
this is all in keynote there's like I
don't know how like 500 animation steps
in this whole deck so hopefully that Oh
so interesting we were given a link hmm
is this big enough can people see okay
so basically I wrote this talk for
Scotland Jess earlier in the year and I
did it there and then after the talk I
broke half of the slides and could not
be bothered to redo all the slides
because it was a total pain in the ass
in keynote to do it so instead I took
the much easier route of writing a tool
which can visualize the JavaScript
runtime at runtime and it's called loop
so let's just run this example and which
was kind of the example we had on the
previous slide
I haven't shimmed xhr yet it's doable I
just haven't done it so as you can see
the code we're going to log something
this is a simple shame around like
document dot add event listener set
timeout and we're gonna do a consular
book so I'm just going to run it and see
what happens so add a Dom API out of
timeout time it's going to count down Co
is going to continue to run pushes the
callback into the queue which runs which
runs the consulate log and we're done if
I click on here then it's going to
trigger the Web API key the callback for
the click and run it if I click a
hundred times we can see what happens
right I clicked the click doesn't get
processed immediately the click has
pushed on to the queue and as the queue
gets processed eventually my click is
going to going to get dealt with right
so I have a few more examples I want to
run run through here except I don't know
how to see tabs so let's just see if I
can find it here we go ok so I'm just
going to run through a few examples just
to kind of talk about a few things that
you might have run into and not kind of
thought about with async api's so in
this example we call set timeout four
times with a one-second delay
and run console dot log hi so if we run
it we can see that we run a few timeouts
but the timeout callbacks get queued
right so that that fourth callback we
asked for a one-second delay and it's
still waiting
the callback hasn't run right so this
kind of illustrates the like what set
timeouts actually doing set timeout is
not a guaranteed time to execution it's
a minimum time to execution just like
set time at zero doesn't run the code
immediately it runs the code next ish
sometime right so in this example I want
to talk about callbacks so depending on
who you speak to and how they phrase
things clawbacks can be one of two
things
callbacks can be any function that
another function calls or callbacks can
be more explicitly an asynchronous
callback as in one that is going to get
pushed on to the callback queue at some
point in the future so this little bit
code illustrates the difference right
the for each method on an array it
doesn't run it takes a function which
you could call a callback but it's not
running it asynchronously right it's
running it within the current stack we
could define an asynchronous for each so
we could it's going to take an array in
a callback and then for each item in the
array it's going to do a set time at
zero with that callback
right I guess this should actually pass
in the value but anyway so I'm going to
run it and we can see what the
difference is so for the first block of
code that runs it's going to sit and
block the stack right until it's
complete whereas in the async version
okay so it's slowed down but we're
basically going to queue a bunch of
callbacks and they're going to clear and
then we can actually run through and do
the console that locks so in this
example the console log is fast so the
benefit of doing it asynchronously isn't
obvious but let's say you're doing some
like slow processing on each each
element in the array
think I have that shown somewhere no no
I don't okay so let's say oops so I have
a delay function which is just slow
right it's just a slow thing so let's
say processing async and here processing
sync okay now I'm going to turn on a
thing I've just been literally hacked
together this morning which is to
simulate the repaint or the render in
the browser so something I haven't
touched on is how all of this interacts
with rendering I kind of touched on it
but yeah not really explained it so
basically the browser is kind of
constrained by what you're doing in
JavaScript right the browser would like
to repaint the screen every 16.6
milliseconds right 60 frames a second is
are ideal like that's as fast as it will
do repaint if it possibly can but it's
constrained by what you're doing in
JavaScript for various reasons so it
can't actually do a render if there is
code on the stack right it's like the
render kind of coal is almost like a
callback itself right it has to wait
till the stack is clear now the
difference is that the render is given a
higher priority than your callbacks so
basically every 16 milliseconds it's
going to queue it's going to cure a
render and then it's going to wait to
the stack is clear before it can
actually do that render so this is this
render queue is just simulating a render
right so every second it's like kind of
do a render yes can I do a render yes
kind of do around yes because our code
isn't doing anything now however if I
run the code we can see that while we're
doing this like slow synchronous loop
through this array our render is blocked
right and if our render is blocked you
can't select text on the screen you
can't click things and see the response
right like that example I showed earlier
in this example okay it's blocked while
we queue up they sync timeouts but
that's relatively quick but we're given
we're kind of giving the Ren
a chance between each element because
we've queued up asynchronously to kind
of jump in there and and undo the render
did that make sense yeah cool so yeah
that's just kind of this is just like a
simulation right of how the rendering
works but it just really shows you like
when people say don't block the event
loop this is exactly what they're
talking about they're saying don't put
shitty slow code on the stack because
when you do that the browser can't do
what it needs to do which is like create
a nice fluid UI right this is why doing
things like image processing or whatever
or like animating too many things just
gets kind of sluggish right if you're
not careful about how you queue up that
code so we're not an example of that we
can see with scroll handlers so scroll
hand like scroll events on in the dom
trigger a lot right like they trigger
like every I presume they trigger on
every frame so like 16 every 16
milliseconds so if I have code like this
right on document dot scroll animate
something or do some work if I have this
code like as I scroll it's just going to
queue up like a ton of callbacks right
and then it has to like go through and
process all of those and if each of the
processing of those is slow then okay
you're not blocking the stack but you're
kind of flooding the Q with Q with
events right so this is like just
helping visualize I guess like what
happens when you actually trigger all
these callbacks so there's ways you can
like debounce that to basically say okay
okay we're going to like queue up all
those events but let's only do those
slow work every like every few seconds
or until the user stops scrolling for
some amount of time cool so I think
that's basically basically it there's
like a whole other talk in how the hell
this works because basically in running
the code like this code runs at runtime
right and it slowed down by I run it
through ass prima which is a JavaScript
parser before and after every single
statement in the code
would I answer a big while loop that
takes half a second um so basically just
like slow motions the code ship it to a
web worker and then do a whole bunch of
stuff to like visualize what's happening
while doing it at runtime that makes
sense so it's like a whole other talk
and all of that but I'm super excited
about it and see what I have is a talk
to anyone after about it because I think
it's kind of neat so with that thanks
very much